kammer vielleicht mein glas wein
besorgen wenn schon kein wein bier also
claudia roth von den grünen bekommen
bastl studio nehmen sie platz
es kann sein dass wir ein bisschen
dreckig werden aber ich glaube sie haben
schon auf angezogen dass auch dreckig
werden
ich wollte gerne etwas sehr deutsches
mit ihnen machen nämlich ein matt igel
das einen mit ihnen für die grüne partei
ist ja mit vielleicht ihr kontrovers
deswegen werden wir einen veganen mett
igel basteln
also man muss bei uns nicht vegan essen
aber man darf man darf sich dann bist du
das essen was du willst
außer andere grüne oder im übertragenen
sinne ja unser veganes matt ist auf
einer reiswaffeln basis das ist aber
doch dass über mit man kinder bestraft
wenn wir noch brav war
anstatt in schokolade zu geben müssen
sie dann reis wasser in essen jetzt
verblödung wir das mal so gut es geht
das ist auch gut wenn man viele hände
geschüttelt hat gut wenn man die hände
vor also lassen sie ihre handy michael
raffl denn ich habe die hände ist gut
drauf aber man könnte ja meinen der
umwelt geht zwar nicht gut so gut wie
draußen geht in dieser welt ziemlich
beschissen und es geht gar nicht gut und
es gibt so viel zu tun aber ich bin gut
drauf weil ich glaube man muss mut haben
und man muss lust haben auf wieder
zustand da müssen wir wirklich alles
roger oder kochen simon stock zu hause
wenn ich ein bisschen urlaub oder so
dann kochen ja nicht ganz ganz nah kommt
übrigens sehr viele stücke schwäbisches
was wir ohne fleisch auskommt hektar und
buben spitze oder für mich wirkt das
jetzt gerade sowie konkrete poesie
wasser
es ist sehr frustrierend wenn man die
dass populisten so im aufschwung sind
also hass verbindet er deutlich mehr als
liebe zu setzen sie nicht auch auf haben
in ihrem vorteil ich mal gelernt habe
dass man nie die methoden des gegners
oder des feindes übernehmen sollte auch
nicht wenn man das hat was wirklich
hartes zweites also wenn sie jetzt
einfach sagen würden wir haben jetzt
alle insassen die nicht okay können sie
das bevor sie das hier noch für den
breit machen muss ja auch noch diese
strukturen jetzt kommen die zwiebeln
dran
ich glaube eine halbe züge erreicht oder
aber die haben ziemliche life skills
life skills nennt man das wenn man so
wir müssen ein bisschen internetsprache
was ist mein tagesgeld ist wenn man halt
so wittern besser umgehen kann wenn man
merkt sogar die macht es sich zum ersten
mal der hat sich ja schon mal was
geschmückte sarg lag also die denke 'ne
halbe rey ja ich glaube schon wollen sie
eine ganze sie können auch eine ganze
wir werden ja wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
knutschen im laufe des interviews also
ich will ja nicht die anti vegan nummer
machen dass eine art sogar auch noch wie
viel ein schneiden wenn sie dann ein
wenn die vegane waffe und wenn man weiß
dass es menschen gibt die erstens gar
kein fleisch essen die zweitens aus
religiösen gründen kein schweinefleisch
essen wollen dann ist diese macht
deutlich was diese leitkultur was dieses
konzept eigentlich heißt es ist eine
wilde was hier fehlt was ein schönes
glas wein für uns so sehr spartanisch
hier alles ich hab so viele oder vegane
sie aber es haben sich schon mal
exklusiven rein existieren ich wollte ja
eigentlich nicht mit ihnen machen
sondern mit volker beck zusammen in
mexiko aber dann hätten wir in polen
drehen müssen unterstrichen
also meist gar nicht ich hab gar nicht
fertig sein so beschließen a das ist
paprika ist da führen wir ein bisschen
paprika 1 zog schramma vielleicht mein
glas wein besorgen jack am glas wein für
claudia für frau claudia haben wir wenn
schon kein wein bier oder cola jetzt
vorm wir die biege machen sie in jungen
igel oder mädchen macht
selbstverständlich mädchen über video
selbstverständlich wenn wir die mehrheit
sind die mädchen überall auf der welt
wenn sie die grünen als männer
feindliche partei bezeichnet nein es
schadet und sie gewählt haben wir diesen
zehn punkte plan entwickelt die zehn
punkte sind so dass man ertragen es
jeder depp versteht wieso haben sie so
einfach gehalten
trauen sie den wähler nicht viel zu auch
der deb hat unrecht wegen pumpe zu
verstehen aber darum geht's ja sagen
sondern es geht darum deutlich zu machen
wohin was so ganz ganz grob
zusammengefasst wohin es gehen soll und
die letzten vier jahre dabei nur gar nix
da hat nur ein verkehrsminister kann man
gar nicht als solchen bezeichnen denn da
kommt jetzt ein bisschen hat auch das
merke ich jetzt das müssten sie doch
eher dobrindt nicht doch gar nicht leben
hinein
aber ich sag mal der ist alles andere
bloß kein verkehrsminister der hat sich
vier jahre mit einer ausländer maut mit
dem ressentiment auseinander gesetzt
anstatt mal zu gucken wie schafft man es
dass 50 prozent der menschen in unserem
land gehen nicht auto fahren auch mobil
sein können aber die e-mobilität ist
schon toll ich habe zwar versucht jetzt
auch offiziell mit einem hybrid auris
hybrid und veganer mit ihrer mischung
aus wieder lernt und eigentlich wollen
wir gemeinsam den igel heben wie man
diesen begriff neu prägen wird würde
vielleicht eine metapher für seine
politischen wir haben jetzt in igls
drüber warteschlange harten hippie
gesagt das machen sie mit ihrem
ich möchte dass die kuh fahren darf ich
so recht auf er hat so starten jetzt in
den bauch von judith a ich finde das gut
können wir im gebet verkaufen was muss
man denn vielleicht probieren einfach
mal original so ohne guten appetit so
schlecht schmeckt das gar nicht als
strom aufnehmen so vielleicht ist das
mein respekt war besser als ich gedacht
dass diese situation war ich vorbereitet
bei würstchen und schmeckt vielen dank
sowohl
[Musik]